hi everybody and welcome to the first
tutorial in a series that will guide you
through building your own 8 ball pool
game using javascript and html5 so
before we begin I would like to take
some time to give a credit to a book
that I read that inspired me of making
this game this book is called building
JavaScript games for phones tablets and
desktop and it is written by Aria Negus
I'm sorry if I'm pronouncing the name
wrong anyway it is a really great book
and many of the topics that I'm going to
talk about during these tutorials are
taken from here and if you would like to
get a deeper understanding and knowledge
about those topics I really recommend
you to read this book you can either
look at my code by getting to my github
page and find this repository that
contains all the code for this project
you can even go down here and you'll
find a working demo that you can enter
and play and experience the game all by
ourselves all right so let's move on so
the first thing we will do is to create
a new folder for this project and maybe
we should give it a significant name
something like classic pool game now I
will open my preferred text editor which
is in my case visual studio code and
drag the newly created folder into it
let's now create a new file and the
first five I'm about to create is the
HTML file let's give it a name index dot
HTML now there are many neat ways to
create the structure of an HTML document
with visual studio code you can just
write HTML and choose this option and
you'll see that the structure is already
built for you but I'm going to delete
all that since I promised to show you
how to build a game from scratch so I'm
gonna write everything myself let's
start with the HTML tag and inside of
that I will create a head tag and a
title and let's give it the same title
as the folder name classic pool game
let's create a body tag and here
we will create a canvas element which
will have an ID of screen and weight
that will change in the future since the
canvas is going to be adoptable to the
screen size but as of right now I'm
going to keep it mm height will be 804
now
and that's it the HTML document is
pretty much complete for this game after
we've created the canvas element on our
HTML file let's now create a JavaScript
object that will let us interact with
this canvas in order to do so we will
need to create a JavaScript file let's
call this file canvas Jes in this file
I'm going to define a function
constructor and let's call this function
constructor canvas 2d the object
eventually will be created using this
function constructor we'll have two data
members the first one will be the start
canvas which will be the canvas itself
and I'm going to fetch that from the
HTML using document dot get element by
ID and here I'm going to send the ID
that I gave to the canvas before screen
as you can see it is the same ID as the
canvas on the HTML file so the second
member is the canvas context and the
canvas context is an object that has
certain functionalities that will make
our lives much easier interacting with
the canvas so in order to get the canvas
context we'll need to approach the
canvas element and ask for the context
get context here I'm going to send to D
since the game is going to be
2-dimensional let's think about the
functionality we would like a canvas 2d
object to have as a fight now I can
think of two things I would like to
clear the canvas using this object and I
would like to draw an image on the
canvas using this object in order to
define this behavior we will need to use
methods I will define the methods on the
prototype of canvas 2d let's do it right
now so canvas
Toodee the prototype not clear equals a
function and here I'm going to use the
clear rect function of the canvas
context let's write canvas context not
clear rect and it will need to get an x
value and a y-value a width and height
so the X will be zero since I want to
clear all of the canvas and the y is
zero and the width will be the canvas
with dot width and the height is going
to be the canvas height canvas dot right
all right so let's move on to the draw
image method I'm going to define it here
canvas 2d dot prototype draw image and
that will be equals a function that will
get an image and a position and it will
use the canvas context to draw that
image on the given position so I will
need to approach the canvas contact and
ask it nicely to draw the image for us I
will send the image that I got and
position dot X and position dot Y so the
next step is to see that everything that
we've done so far is actually working as
expected in order to do so I will go to
the index dot HTML file and add a
reference to the script that we just
wrote so script SRC and that will be
equal as canvas dot J yes and that's it
the second thing that we need is an
image to check the draw image method and
I already dragged the assets folder into
the new folder that we've created for
this project in order to find the assets
folder you can go to my github page I
will leave a link down in the
description below and you can download
the assets all right now that we are
ready let's create a new object using
the function constructor that we built
before so let's call this object canvas
and it will be equals a new canvas to
the object
now in order to test the drill image
method I'm going to create a new image
so let's call it image and just to make
it clear it will comment here that it is
just for testing okay so here the image
will be equals a new image and here I
will need to define the source for this
image the path of the image image dot
SRC and that will be equals and I know
the path but if you want if you want to
make sure you can just open the assets
folder and see where this image is so I
will write it down it's done / assets /
sprites / pass PR background dot PNG all
right
there is an issue that we need to
consider here since it's gonna take a
while for the image to load but the
script is going to be rendered
immediately so we cannot just write
something like canvas dot draw image and
just send the image and the position
that we want because that just won't
work if I open the index dot HTML file
you see that nothing is displayed on
screen even though we have no errors so
only for testing and to see that
everything that we've done so far is
working I will set a timeout down here
below and inside of the callback
function I will paste this code and set
the timeout for one second and let's see
if now that is working yes okay so now
you can see that the background image is
displayed on screen
let's check the clear method that we
wrote before so I will just write canvas
start clear and let's refresh the page
and you see now that the canvas is empty
so let's go back to our code and delete
this line cuz I prefer to see something
displayed on screen before we finish the
first part and let's see that everything
works yeah great
as you can see the background image was
drawn on the canvas but there's only a
minor issue you can see that the image
is a little bit cropped down here so in
order to fix that I will change the
dimensions of the canvas to match the
dimensions of the background image so
the width should be 1500 and the height
should be 825 now as i refresh the page
you can see that the
image is no longer cropped so let's go
back to our code and delete all those
lines we used for testing let's save and
now create a new javascript file that
will go assets dot j s here eventually
I'm going to declare functions that will
help me deal with loading the assets for
the game but first I'm going to create a
new object and let's call this object
sprites and it will be equal an empty
object let's create another variable
that will call assets still loading and
let's set it to 0 let's declare a new
function and let's call this function
load assets and this function is going
to take as an argument a callback
function so once it finishes to load all
the assets is going to activate this
callback function here I want to write
something like sprites dot background
equals load sprite and I want to pass
the file name which is located on the
sprites folder in my case that will be s
PR underscore background dot PNG in
order for that to work I will need to
declare another function here and I will
call this function load sprite and this
function will take as an argument a file
name and the first thing it's gonna do
is to increase the number of assets that
are still loading then I will create an
image for this sprite sprite image
equals new image object and I'm going to
define the source of this image to be
the path of the sprites folder which is
assets slash sprites slash
plus the file name now I'm going to use
the unload property of the image object
and I'm going to define that once the
image is done loading
I want to decrease the number of assets
that are still loading now I will return
I will return the image we can use the
load sprite function that we just wrote
to load all the sprites of the game but
for now I will load just one more
so sprites dot stick equals load sprite
and I will send the file name of the
stick image so that will be on SPR stick
dot PNG and we cannot activate the
callback function yet because we cannot
know for sure that all the images are
downloading in order to validate that we
need to create another function and I
will call this function assets loading
loop and this function will get us an
argument the same callback function that
we received on the load assets function
inside this function I'm gonna do
something if assets are still loading
and else I'm going to do something else
so if the assets are still loading I
want to enter the loop again so I'll use
the request animation frame method of
the window object in order to send the
assets loading loop as a callback
function and I'm going to bind this and
the argument that I got which is the
callback
else I want to activate the callback
function so I will just go callback
finally we will need to call the assets
loading loop from within the load assets
function so let's just copy that and
paste it here and let's just send a
callback function that we got as an
argument and that's it well for now
that's pretty much what we need in
assets GS we're going to use all the
code that we wrote here very soon let me
organize my code a bit before we move on
so I just delete some of the spaces here
and add more spaces here and here and
maybe there alright so we are done now
let's create the most important object
on our project and for that I'm going to
create a new file and call this file
game GS and here I'm going to define a
function constructor and call this
function constructor game the game
object will contain three methods let's
write them down so the first one is game
the prototype dot in it so here we will
initialize the game the second one will
be game dot prototype dot start so you
can imagine that here we will start the
game and the third one is game dot
prototype dot main loop and in this
function pretty much everything is going
to happen before I write anything inside
those methods I want to create another
object and this object will be called
the game world let's create another
function constructor and call this
function constructor game world the game
world will be an object that will
contain all the physical objects of the
game and in each frame of animation it
will be responsible
to update them and to draw them on the
canvas in order for him to do that
we'll need to define some methods so the
first method will be the update method
and the second method should be the draw
method now I'll go back to the game
dodge a gas file and here on the init
method I'm going to create a new member
for the game object and I'm going to
call this member game world and this
game world will be the new game world
object that we created now down here I'm
going to create a new object that will
be of the type game so I'm going to call
this object pool game and it will be
equal a new game object let's now deal
with the start method of the game object
so here the first thing I want to do is
to call the init function and then I
want to call the main loop and on the
main loop the first thing we want to do
is to clear the canvas and for that we
can use the canvas object that we
created in the previous video so just
write canvas not clear after that we
want to update the game world so we can
just use pool game in order to approach
the game world and then to call the
update function and then we want to draw
the game world so we can go to pool game
dot game world dot go
and then we'll use the
requestanimationframe method of the
window object the same method that we
used before to call the same loop so
let's just write requestanimationframe
and we can call pool game dot main loop
now I'll go back to the game world j/s
file and here on the draw method I'm
going to use the canvas object in order
to draw an image and the image will be
the background image so sprites dot
background and the position will be X
will be 0 and Y will be 0 the next step
is to open the index dot HTML file and
to add references to all of the script
files that we wrote so I want to waste
your time I will just paste that here
and another thing that we'll need to do
is to write a small script and in the
script I'm going to call the load assets
function that we wrote and as an as a
callback I'm going to pass pool game dot
start so when it finishes loading all
the assets it's going to call this
function this method on the pool game
object that will start the game let's
try and open the index dot HTML file on
our browser and let's see if we get
something well no let's check for errors
and yep this dot in it is not a function
at the game dot start oh ok so this is a
common issue in JavaScript what happened
here is that we passed a function to
another up
to activate and in this process the dis
reference changed so now that this
reference is no longer the pool game it
is the window object because load assets
is a function that sits in the window
object in order to fix that we need to
go to the game dot j ass file and here
instead of calling this dot in it will
call pool game dot in it and pulling dot
main loop let's go back to our browser
and refresh and now you can see that the
background image is displayed on screen
to make it interesting let's add another
object to our game I'll go back to our
code and here I will create a new file
and I'll call this file stick dot GS and
another function constructor so function
stick and the stick object without fun
for now a position so this dot position
equals X will be zero and Y will be 400
the stick object will also have an
update method and a draw method let's
write them down so stick dot prototype
dot update equals a function and stick
the prototype dot Rho equals function
and inside the draw function I want to
call the canvas object and to draw an
image and the image that I'm going to
draw is the spite of the stick that we
loaded before so sprites dot stick
I want to draw it on the current
position of the stick so let's use this
dot position inside the update method I
just want to write some stop code in
purpose of testing so let's just leave a
comment here and I will mention that it
is just for testing and I'm going to
increase in every frame of animation the
x value of the position of the stick by
one so this dot position dot X plus plus
now in our game world let's add a member
and this member will be the stick and it
will be a new stick object and inside
the update function I'm going to call
this dot stick dot update and after I
will draw the background image I want to
call this dot stick dot row the final
step for now is to open the index dot
HTML file and to add a reference to the
stick dot J's file that we wrote
so script SRC and here I'm going to
write stick dot J s and save it I will
open the index dot HTML file on my
browser and now you can really see the
main loop in action so let's delete
those lines of code that we use for
testing let's save and now create a new
JavaScript file that will call vector 2
dot J s here I will define a new
function constructor that its purpose is
to help us deal with our automatic
operations between vectors let's call
this function
instructor vector2 and it will get two
arguments so the first one will be an x
and a y a vector two object will have
two members that goes by the same names
as those arguments
so let's write them down this dot X and
it will be equal if type of the X
argument is different from undefined it
will be equal the value of the X
argument else it will be a zero and
let's do the same for the Y so this dot
Y if typeof Y is not undefined that will
be equal Y the Y argument and else that
will be zero let's save and that will do
for now in the future we'll add more
functionality to the vector two
definition let's now create a new folder
and call this folder input and inside
this folder I'm going to create a new
file that I'll call button state dot j/s
the button state object will be a simple
object that will indicate whether a
certain button is pressed or down so
let's create a new function constructor
new function constructor and call this
function constructor a button state and
let's initialize this dot down to be
false and this dot pressed to be false
now I will create another file inside
this folder and this file will go by the
name of mouse Jas here obviously we will
end our mouse input and for that I will
need a mouse endler so let's define a
mouse and ler object and the mouse
handler will contain three button States
one for every button on our mouse and a
position that will be of type vector to
the type that we created before so let's
write it down this dot left equals new
button state this dot middle equals new
button state and this dot right equals
new button straight object now the
position this position will be
initialized to a a new vector2 object
now I will define that once there is a
mouse movement so on mouse move we'll
call a function that will write just in
one second
so I will call this function handle
mouse move and document on Mouse down I
will call another function and mouse
down and finally document on mouse up I
will call handle mouse up
let's save all right so now let's create
a new object of the type mouse and layer
that we just defined so I will call this
object mouse that Mouse be equal a new
mouse Handler and now I will implement
the functions that we wrote here so
Endel mouse move I'll just create a new
function and I will call it and the
mouse move and by default it's going to
get an event so let's fetch let's fetch
from the event the mouse position so we
can get the mouse x value by going to
the page x property inside the event
object so let Y be equal the event dot
page Y now we can set the mouse dot
position to be a new vector new vector2
and send the arguments x and y let's
save okay so let's move on to the next
function handle mouse down and this
function is also going to get an event
as an argument and before I write
anything inside this function I want to
call the Ender mouse move function and
send the same event so I will get the
current position of the mouse then let
me paste a little bit of code here and
then I will explain exactly what is
going on inside this code if a certain
button on our mouse is down we would
like to set the down property of the
correspondent button state to be
we also want to check if the button was
down before that because if not we want
to set the pressed property of the same
button state to be true and also the
event object as an attribute that is
called which that indicates which button
on our mouse is currently down and if
the which attribute is one that means
that the left button on our mouse is
down if it is too that means that the
middle button on our mouse is down and
if it is free that means that the right
button on our mouse is down so that's
exactly what you see here in the code I
will just fix those underscores here so
let's move on to the next function and I
will just paste that here and as you can
see it is very similar we just check the
attribute on the event to see which
button was released and we set the down
property of the correspondent button
state to be false just one final thing
that we need here is an option to reset
the mouse input so I will define another
function or actually method on the
prototype of Mouse Sandler and I will
call this function this method reset
that will be equals a function and here
I want to set this dot left dot pressed
to be false this dot middle dot pressed
to be false and this dot right not
pressed to be false
on our HTML file I want to add
references to all of the script files
that we wrote so I will just paste that
here and another thing that I want to do
is to reset the mouse input in every
iteration of the main loop so here after
I draw the game world I want to call
mouse dot reset the last thing I want to
do just to test that everything that
we've done so far is working I want to
set the position of the stick to be
equal the mouse position and I want to
do something if mouse dot left is
pressed so pressed so if that happens I
want to log a message
so console dot log and I will just write
pressed left okay and I will mention
that it is just for testing as we always
do so now when I open the index dot HTML
file on my browser you could see that
the stick object is tracking the
movement of the mouse and if I inspect
that you'll see that every time I click
the left button on my mouse you will see
a new message here in the console so of
course that's not the kind of behavior
we want in our game but that's an
important step because now we know how
to handle the mouse input there is
something that bothers me about this
implementation because even though the
stick and
the mouse shared the same position you
can see that the mouse is all the way to
the left and it's not on the center of
the stick the reason that happens is
because when we draw the stick using the
canvas context we give it a position and
the canvas context treats this position
as the top left corner of the image so
in order to fix that we'll need to
introduce a new vector that will call
the origin of the object in the campus
DOJ's file we'll change the
implementation of the draw image method
will add another argument that will go
origin before we do anything else here
let's just validate that the position
that we got to this function is not null
or undefined so if it is we should set
it to be a new vector2 object and that
will mean that is x and y values will be
zeros let's do the same for the origin
so if not origin origin will be a new
vector2 object and now we can use the
canvas context save method in order to
save the current state of the context
then we can make changes in it and then
we can restore it to the same state so
this dot canvas context dot save and now
we can translate the context to a
different position so this dot canvas
context dot translate position dot X and
position dot Y
now in the draw image method of the
canvas context we don't need to send the
position anymore we can just delete that
and instead send the origin that means
where we want to draw our top left
corner so - origin dot X and - origin
dot y and that's of course relative to
the position that we are in right now
and now we can restore the canvas
context to the last saved state so now
let's go back to the stick dot JS file
and let me fix this position to be a new
vector2 object and let's set it randomly
to be 400 by 400 and let's add a new
property this dot origin and set it to
be a new vector and for now we'll set it
to be 500 by 10 and now in the draw
method of the stick object I can just
add this origin and let's see what
happens
so let's refresh the browser and now you
can see that the pointer is on the
middle of the stick on the assets ES
file let's load another sprite and let's
call this bright white ball and
obviously that will be the sprite of the
white ball and the image is located on
SPR underscore white ball dot PNG now I
will create a new file that go by the
name of Bo Jes and here I'm going to
define a new constant that I'll call
ball origin and I'm going to set it to
be a new vector of 25 by 25 now I will
define a new function constructor that I
will call ball and it will get as an
argument of position and I will set this
dot position to be the position that we
got as an argument
and let's write two functions for the
ball object so bowled out prototype dot
update equals new function and ball dot
ball prototype dot Rho equals a function
and here I'm going to call the canvas
and to draw an image and just for now
I'm going to draw the white balls image
even though not all the balls in the
game are going to be white but it is
just for now and the position will be
this dot position and the origin will be
the ball's origin constant so let's go
to the index dot HTML file and add a
reference to the script file that we
just wrote so here I will write script
SRC and bold arching s now let's go to
the game world and add a new member and
let's call this member white ball and it
will be equal a new ball object with a
new position on the update method I want
to update our new member so this dot
white ball dot update and inside the row
method I want to draw the white ball so
this dot white ball dot grow back in the
browser let's refresh and we can see
that the white ball is drawn on the
canvas back in our code let's go to the
stickiest file and I will change the
function constructor of the stick to get
a position from outside so this dot
position will be equal the position
argument that we got
and also I'm going to define a new
constant that I'm going to call stick
origin and it will be equal a new
vector2 of 970 by 11 now on the Joe
function I don't need to send this the
origin anymore I will send the stick
origin and I'm going to delete the this
dot origin member now I'll go to the
game world and here I'm going to set the
position of the stick to be the same as
the position of the white ball and back
in stick J ass I will comment out all
this code that we wrote for testing back
in our browser let's refresh and now you
can see the positions of the white ball
and the stick don't worry
in few moments you will realize why we
did all that ok so there's another
aspect that I want to add to the game
and it is the rotation of the stick and
I found this really good article online
that explains exactly what I'm going to
do in the code so I'm going to leave a
link down below to this article and also
explain it briefly so let's say that
here instead of a cat we have a stick
and this is the position of the mouse so
we want to rotate the stick so it will
point towards the mouse how are we going
to do that we need to find this angle
for that so in order to find this angle
we need to find the opposite and the
adjacent and in order to find the
opposite we can subtract the stick Y
position from the mouse Y position and
in order to find the adjacent we can
subtract the stick x position from the
mouse ax
position so we know that tangent of this
angle is opposite / adjacent so we can
just apply the arctangent function on
both sides and then we can find this
angle back in stage is let's delete
those lines of code that we use for
testing and let's add a new property
that will call this dot rotation and
initially it will be 0 now let's add a
new method to the stick object and let's
call this method update rotation and
that will be equal Afshin now we need to
calculate the opposite so let opposite
be mouse dot position dot Y minus this
dot position dot y and adjacent be Mouse
the odd position dot X minus this dot
position dot X and now we can use the
arctangent function inside the math
class so math eight and two and we can
send the opposite and the adjacent and
we'll get the angle to this dot rotation
and inside the update method I'm going
to call this dot update rotation finally
we'll open the canvas dot JS file and
update the draw image method so it will
get also a rotation and let's give it a
default value of zero and here after we
save the canvas context state we can
rotate the canvas contacts
so they start canvass contacts dot
rotate and here I'm going to send the
rotation and inside stick Jas I'm going
to send this dot rotation to the draw
image method let's save and now go back
to our browser and refresh and now you
can see that the stick is rotating so it
points towards the position of my mouse
okay so let me give you a little
challenge if you code alongside with me
you already have all the tools to
implement the next step here you'll see
that when I press the left button on my
mouse the stick is being pulled away
from the white ball and once I release
it it shoots the ball towards the
position of the mouse so let me
demonstrate okay great so give it a shot
here in vector 2 Jas
instead of validating that x and y are
now undefined we can just use some
default parameters so let's change that
and X will be 0 by default and Y will be
0 as well and let's add another method
to the vector 2 class so vector 2 dot
prototype dot copy and that will be
equal a new function and here I will
return a new vector 2 with the same
properties as this vector so this dot X
and this dot Y in stick Dodge is I will
bring back this dot origin and I will
set it to be a copy of the stick origin
constant so stick origin copy and in the
draw method I will send this dot origin
instead instead of the stick origin
alright I'll zoom in because it's a bit
difficult to see the code this way
alright that's much better now I will
add another property that I would call
this dot power and I will set it
initially to be 0 and I will create
another method for the stick class then
I'll call increase power and it will be
equal a function and here I'm going to
increase the power but by let's say 100
and the origin that's the origin I will
increase it by 5 um no actually this is
our origin dot X so now in the update
method I'm going to define that once the
left button on the mouse is down I want
to increase the power so this dot
increase power and let's go to the
browser and see the effect that it makes
okay let's refresh and now when I click
the left button on my mouse you can see
that that the stick is being pulled away
from the white bowl here in the function
constructor of the stick I'm going to
send another argument that I would call
on shoot and this argument would be
actually a function so let's set this
dot on shoot to be on shoot and here in
the update method if the left button is
not down anymore and this dot power is
greater than zero
I want to call this dot shoot not not on
shoot now I want to call a function that
I will define right here a method
actually so stick dot prototype dot
should equal a function and inside this
function I'm going to call
this dot on shoot and I'm going to send
this dot power and this dot rotation now
let's open the board ojs file and here
I'm going to add another another method
to the ball class so ball dot prototype
dot shoot and that will be equal
function that will get power and
rotation and just for now let's log a
message to the console so console dot
log shoot and in the game world
when we create a stick object let's send
as an argument this function that we
created just now this dot white ball dot
shoot back in stick dodge is after we
activate the on shoot function let's set
this dot power to be zero back in the
browser now you'll see that every time I
release the left button on my mouse a
new message is logged into the console
back in stick dodge is I'm going to set
another constant that I will call the
stick shot origin and it will be a new
vector of nine hundred and fifty by
eleven and now in the shoot function I'm
going to set this dot origin to be a
copy of the short origin
now back in the browser let's refresh
and now you'll see that every time I
release the left button on my mouse it
seems like the stick is moving forward
towards the ball alright so in the shoot
method of the ball object we would like
to find the velocity that the ball
should have and we get two parameters
the first one is the power and the
second one is the rotation so in this
growing let's assume that this is the
center of the ball and here is the
position of my mouse so we know that
this angle is the same as the rotation
that was sent into this method okay so
if we'll assume that the distance
between this point and this point is one
we know for sure that the velocity
should be a new vector to that its x
value will be cosine of this angle and
is Y value will be sine of the same
angle here in the game world I'm just
going to bind this shoot function that
we sent as an argument to this dot white
bow just to make sure that we won't lose
the reference to the white ball and here
in the in both OJS I'm going to add a
new property that I will call this dot
velocity and it will be a new vector to
object and inside the shoot method I'm
going to set this dot velocity to be a
new vector to that it's x value will be
math dot cosine of the rotation
and it's why value should be math dot
sign of the rotation now inside the
update method I want to add the velocity
to the position of the ball so I'm going
to write this dot position dot add two
and to send this dot velocity and of
course that now I need to implement the
add to method inside the vector to class
so here I will write vector to dot
prototype dot had two and it will get
another vector as an argument and here
I'm going to set this dot X to be this
dot X plus vector dot X so this dot y
plus equal vector dot Y and I need to
fix that so that will be equal of on and
now back in the browser when I shoot the
ball you'll see that it goes slowly
towards the position of the pointer so
now in the shoot method we can use the
power that we got as an argument and we
can multiply the velocity by this power
and in the game world I'm going to
introduce a new constant that I will
call Delta and I will set it to be 1/100
and this will represent how much I want
to update on each iteration so it's
fraction that will send to the update
method of the ball so it will only
update a fraction of the velocity so
this dot velocity dot mold and we'll
send the Delta and of course that now we
need to implement
the mold method on the vector 2 class so
vector 2 dot prototype dot mold and it
will be a function that will get as an
argument as Kahler and will return new
vector to this dot X multiplied by the
scalar and this dot y multiplied by the
same scalar now back in Bordeaux je s we
can use the same method in order to
simulate friction so we can use we can
set this dot velocity to be mm to be
this dot velocity dot x 0.98 and now
let's test the results on our browser so
let me refresh and let's shoot the ball
and that looks quite nice so that's it
for this video thank you very much for
watching it and stay tuned for more
good bye